we cannot rely on the courts Congress
has kind of rendered itself useless the
executive I think is truly the only way
we can save this country is by using
that authority to you know defund
different agencies and do things like
that and just totally go after this
woken weaponized deep State this
bureaucracy so I think you know this is
really the most important election
because it's kind of our last chance but
if it's if it's about funding then the
Republicans are in a position now where
they should be able to do it because
they have they they have they don't have
the Senate like you have the Office of
Management and budget if you're
president you can totally cut agents
budget or agencies oh I mean look fair
enough the Republicans are going to vote
on this Government funding bill and
they're absolutely going to fund all of
these intelligence agencies and law
enforcement agencies that are being
weaponized against Trump and Trump
supporters the Republicans have the
power right now to Simply Be Like We
will not vote on any funding for the
government that includes funding for the
FBI